[Music]
Steve what's your inro again where we
are very very afraid of everybody very
very
afraid sounds so inspired I can't wait
till this goes out to the world all
right so continuing off the conversation
from our last one hey what is your least
favorite thing about your
ethnicity damn the least favorite thing
about Miami
genocide
I think I'm with you on that don't we
all have
so I'll Circle
back yeah they're actually is because
for for Chinese they genocided
themselves yeah there's a lot of
genocide yeah I mean you know Japanese
folks were access powers my
least oh [__] that's a tough damn my
least I'm done I'll see you guys I'm
going to go outside get some a no this
is when you got to go in dude okay if
you want to
be the true white savior you got to talk
about how bad white men are oh yeah yeah
yeah I would say uh you got to go all in
it's kind of lightweight but it's the
rigid The Stereotype of how rigid
Japanese folks are to the rules so like
they're so like everything is about like
the rules so they don't they don't know
how to [__] bend and be a human a
little bit so it's like hey if we're
opening at between the hours of 3: to
5:00 p.m. then you better be there at
[__] 3:00 p.m. exactly and they won't
just they won't sway from it it won't be
like 2:59 I you can come in it's like
you stupid is that just really strong
discipline I don't think they understand
how to think flexibly so it's just like
they have these rules in place cuz it
works with their whole entire system so
if there's a little bit of a curveball
thrown at them they just
malfunction yeah which makes a really
strict world so strict everything is
like has to be perfect I don't like that
you know what I honestly do hate about
about white people right now like
honestly is all this [__] lexury
[__] like all over Twitter and
everywhere like just stop lecturing
people about every [__] thing
everything's a teachable moment what's
the what's the lecturing thing on
Twitter and everything everything dude
it's like the FYI kind of [__] about
culture and like about everything yeah
it's like oh just shut up or like the
the whole even just like you know like
Nick say white savior [__] it's like
yeah we got it dude like okay so like
you're going to say the talking point
for someone else because your voice is
so much more eloquent or whatever you
think it is right right where do you
think that comes from that you're more
heard it's a true honest internalized
superiority thing I think like you
really do think you're a better
messenger for whatever the [__] it is
and I think it's is that the same thing
as being like the host that does like
all Steve day and like doesn't [__]
compliment the other host are we doing
host PVP right now that's fine I'm I'm
no this just discussion you know this is
off the Record host PVP I've been uh
I've been pretty polite to you today so
that's what this video becomes about
that can change no but I I I I just
think I mean yeah if I do an article way
better than you that's not because of my
race we should do articles that's not a
deeply internalized before I say
something no it's because before I say
something I don't have to say 5 6 S8 in
my
head that has nothing to do with the
race
just you know profession based yeah okay
okay I'm going to go cry
now oh you know what I didn't like about
white people this is my own uh this is
my own personal experience for what I
don't know if the Next Generation had
this but uh I didn't I felt like there
was a a very strong dividing line
between Filipino Americans and like
fobs which is like I'm sure that happens
all the time but it was very much like a
uh you just wanted so badly not to be
considered a
fob like you made fun of the other guys
that had Filipino accents that were here
which I think is like naturally that's
going to happen but also I think
Filipinos as a response to that being
such a bad thing in My Generation the
Next Generation became too gatekeep
about how you're supposed to feel and
it's like a
overcorrection I think there's a lot of
overcorrecting going around which I
think is like a thing where like um what
I mean by that is like now it's like
swinging the other way where like other
Filipinos will be on your ass about how
you're supposed to feel about the
Filipino culture which is [__] dumb
to me like I don't think I think
everybody's experience is so different
and nuanced and depending on where they
are in the diaspora it's like you can
feel how you feel like it's just the
result of how you grew up but then now
it's like now that we have next shark
and [__] it's like everybody's policing
each other's everyone's policing each
other's Pride which I think is stupid
you know what I mean also investigating
each other's authenticity all the time
right yeah it's like full bore
investigations of how authentically
you're doing something yeah yeah yeah
and I feel like the the the base level
achievement you can come off with is
just not doing that anymore which is not
doing what I grew up with was making fun
of and dividing the Social Circle
between you got an accent we don't we're
cooler you guys are whack like that was
bad but I don't know if that still
happens but I think most people from my
generation came off of that grew up out
of and went oh we were [__] whack for
that and I think that's cool I don't
think we got to do more than that I
think that's good like that's a really
big step you but the more time you spend
talking about something like that the
more I know you're just really really
insecure about it you know what I mean
you're just super deeply insecure about
whatever it is with you it's like the
guys who talk about like wanting to be
good at sex a little too much it's like
oh you're not good at it and you're just
really sad about that you know you know
so then you spend all your time talking
about how you wish [__] didn't care
so much about penis size and all that
stuff exactly yeah yeah just move on
dude I think again that's an Asian
that's a Filipino ameran problem I think
it's actually an immigrant immigrant
country thing like I've noticed that
about everybody here in America like
even with white folks right there's just
wanting to like legitimize belong like
who's more rightfully
like and who has the actual
representation of the culture and I
think that's even happening like in all
different areas sure yeah where it's
like I think that's what happens when
you have a society that isn't really
indigenous to the space and people have
to legitimize them belonging it's an
similation race yeah so then it's
probably been going on for like hundreds
of years here uh
the cool difference is that I remembered
Koreans not having that I remembered
Koreans being proud of like all KP
Korean just KP across the board just
like oh you're Korean cool I'm Korean
cool and then they all like you know
even if they didn't speak Korean they
were still like they were way stronger
of a unified Social Circle than like
Filipinos yeah cuz Koreans would do the
like Hispanic thing where if they say
their native word in English they go
full boore
you know how like oh would you like to
have some burritos like all Hispanic
people do that right and then even
Koreans is like that too they be like
hey would you like to have some
Su they always like they have to say the
full thing but then like in Chinese you
don't do that you're like oh you guys
want to get like uh like be beef chow or
something they don't go like
CH but then for them it's like it's
almost be more better to be more
connected yeah back to the home country
right right we got to start doing that
they're the only ones that do that the
only Asians it does jump out at you kind
of right it's jarring yeah it is that's
such a
[__] when you introduce the toolic
word do you go full bore or is it like
more of the Americanized version of the
I it depends if I'm if I'm talking to
other Filipino Americans I'll just say
it however but if I'm speaking to people
that speak Tagalog then I'll I'll
Tagalog it up a little bit Hispanics
would just say it doesn't even matter it
could be like someone that doesn't even
speak the language just go full bore on
that thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right that's a really good that's a
really good exp true statement yeah yeah
yeah like even if they say the city like
Soul go I was just
in I'm like dude you don't got to spit
at that's also that's also doing part to
like growing up where your parents said
it like that but then we I came from a
weird generation that was like all about
hiding hiding your uh ethnicity a little
bit it's like no we need you to blend in
with this like new place so like my
parents never spoke to go around me
because they were like we don't want you
picking up this accent because they were
they were dealing with that at work
about with with like other people making
them feel or like going out with feeling
like oh people are looking at us
differently because we don't speak
perfect English and [__] hey do you guys
want to go get some fud or you guys want
to go get some f see right see F don't
just throw it in your face like that
don't spit him my face yeah it's funny
because the first thing I didn't like
was the discrimination and now I don't
like the
hyper policing so I don't know if that's
just like me being [__] cuz I think
the it rubber banded way bad you know I
think the thing I didn't like about
Chinese growing up was I was like can
Chinese people just do something cool
for
once like like nothing was like nothing
was cool like like you know like um like
even supermarkets right like one has
flies in it and then the other one's
like Hmart and they're like dude Hmart
is [__] sick why is that so sick or
like you have like San Rio and then you
got Morning Glory like just even pencil
boxes and [__] and then you got [__]
like mothball scented [__] pens or
whatever that you find at 99 wrench like
nothing was ever nothing was ever cool I
think it's grass is greener cuz my
cousin was so obsessed with like Kung Fu
he's like I don't want to [__] do
karate he goes Japanese [__] is so rigid
and lame and then he's all like but
Chinese [__] cuz he liked Bruce Lee
and then the he's like he like the silk
like Gees and [__] like that's all we
had though cuz yeah cuz I hated kungu
too Jin the
MC Jin the MC made Chinese people yeah
but that's like rap culture like he was
pulling something else in that's harder
than to be a martial artist [__] Guru
yeah cuz even the Chinese like I wanted
to do karate cuz it was like it was like
a hard style it looked [__] dope I'm
doing this
[__] [__] like slapping your own
feet and [__] what the [__] is slapping
my own feet [__] I want to break a board
I want to do something that's [__]
hardcore you didn't like the [__]
spear
dodging like I'm doing all this [__]
flowery [__] I'm like that's [__]
whack [__] even our snacks aren't
packaged as well as Japanese and Korean
snacks that was the biggest thing you
about I'm eating [__] sour plums and
[__] there's like the supermarket sucked
ass our our our [__] uh Chinese our
our Stone Cold Steve Austin was [__]
Jackie
who's like [__] falling over every
[__] day jaie ch's the best dude so
cool I was with you the whole time jaie
by the way by the way look at me Jackie
greater than Bruce Lee I truly really
what I'm saying is it would be nice if
he was cool have a good he's lovable but
he wasn't like Bruce it's like Chinese
lack like swagness swagness Chan was
like the Buster Keaton like he wasn't
supposed to be but he still kind of like
lowkey a womanizer off camera so we
didn't have we just didn't have Bronx he
did all his own stunts for so many years
and [__] that guy I respected all of
that stuff I see what you mean though I
see what you mean like the he's talking
about the cool like I think they it's
like lacking maybe like SE attitude or
like something that's like missing that
you maybe you looked in other like
groups where it's like Koreans are
executing their movies and something so
like with a cool Factor yeah like even
like K-pop like even as like as goofy as
Sai is he's cool still there's something
that's like cool about him you know Sai
is cool I thought Sai was cool Sai or
Jackie Chan I think size's cool than
Jackie Chen just as like in terms of
cool Factor not influence or or
dominance you [__] lost me bro yeah
he lost me too I'm sorry dude I was so
pumped yeah I was like you had me at
[__] sour plums like all the way I
was learning a lot and then I now I'm
out he said sigh is cool than Jackie
you're like not like in terms of cool
Factor not overall is that do no matter
how much you quote it I'm just not with
you dude do you think that's because
like in in Chinese like design of
anything like cool is not the first
thing they
want too practical yeah the practicality
like beats everything maybe or maybe
they grow their [__] whiskers isn't
cool man like why you growing it like
that Chinese culture is
so uninfluenced by Western that they
have their own cool like Indian it's
they have their own cool so different
that like when you look at it from a
western lens or just even a different
culture just like what is this [__] even
the
sounds with all the Black Keys where's
the [__] soul in the [__] music
man it just sounds like [__] wrong
rubber bands wrong rubber bands he lost
me after the Jackie thing out yeah yeah
everything you say right now is just
wrong I get it I get what you're saying
you guys no because it's true it's like
when it's like a lot of the coolest
things are born from like lower income
like poor places I know what you mean I
see where you're coming from with that
that's true because like everybody's
that's connected to the world right like
they add to the influences of what's
cool so for example like Punk like you
could have Punk scene in Japan Europe
America or like hip-hop right and then
they'll add a little to it and then just
recently China India and some other
countries are getting onto it yeah dude
so then I think like they've been in the
bubble for so long that like they just
evolved differently in what they think
is cool yeah that's true so like even
their Warriors come out in silk P like
panties and [__] you know what I mean so
it's a different world I feel like it's
that thing of like uh like if you told
the Chinese guy his your business is not
cool he's like what you mean make profit
that's
cool like that's the response I expect
him to have but then like you have like
other things where like they don't
necessarily generate a lot of money yeah
but they're just so Co hey taxes all
cash that's true that's that's true
that's like Japanese where it's like
we're negative every year but we're so
[__] cool yeah yeah we'll slave away
at the job 15 hours a day it's like but
it's so respected though or it's like
the birth of Hip Hop like all that [__]
in New York nobody was making money
money off of it and they still most of
them never have but it's the coolest
[__] thing like ever you know what I
mean doesn't make any money some people
going to get upset at me for this but uh
growing up for on the Vietnamese side of
my culture I [__] hated the sound of
the language really I agree with you the
way that yeah the way that people
stereotype and make fun of Vietnamese
language and sounds like you're [__]
swallowing buckets of water like you're
drowning or whatever yeah like
swallowing buckets of you know what I
mean and you're just like [__] dude
you're not wrong you know what I mean so
there was there was like speaking of
cool like there was such like a non swag
to like the sound of Vietnamese what in
class when I found out there was a
Vietnamese person like doing like open
house or whatever it made me feel better
oh that's good cuz Japanese and Korean
sound is so cool and then Chinese it's
kind of like it's like on the on the
border yeah it's like weird edges
and then you're like [__] man all my
friends going to [__] make fun of me
and [__] and then the minute you have a
Vietnamese like I hear I'm like oh good
like there's another punching
back it's not
just did you ever meet anybody who could
swag it out like really well I think um
people who just had like swagy voices do
it right now speak Vietnamese swagged
out to the
max how do you swag a for this I feel
like people from the north speak more uh
like uh eloquent so it's like uh like in
in the South if you're like uh if I want
to go home like that right and it's just
very like quick and like sharp and yeah
but if you were saying it from the north
you be like
uh oh damn that sounded nice cane you
know what I'm saying like it would just
have a different drowning slower sounded
drowning
slower sounded good it's very throaty
yeah it's just it's still like drinking
buckets of water just thick thicker
viscosity of the water it sounds like it
would give you a headache if you talk
like that for an
[Laughter]
hour speaking of genocide though one
thing one thing growing up genocide that
was really
embarrassing I think uh super
embarrassing was like how Japanese just
copied everything but they couldn't
invent anything ooh so like from break
dance like they would just copy [__]
that got popular right right like break
dancing suring orever cholos and low
riders yeah and then like they would
Master it do it so good now they have
their own style but in the '90s like and
it was so lame like they had Rock Steady
Tokyo right they had all these like
different break dancing and they were so
lame like so off they so lame yeah it
was so bad but I mean I guess it's like
Natural Evolution right like it has to
start somewhere but then when you looked
at the American Crew and just how they
were doing [__] it was so much better it
was so much
cooler but I don't know technology too
they perfected a lot of technological
things that were created elsewhere right
maybe but it just felt like it just felt
like there was no originality in the
culture cuz I wasn't looking at like
ancient [__] I was just looking at like
their fashion like from what they were
wearing to like and then I was like man
you guys are so lame Joe not looking at
Japanese ancient [__] is like blowing my
mind me too I don't believe it really
you're stuck in present day that's
weird I do think the more I've learned
about different places the more I
realize everybody ripped everybody else
off Perpetual dude like go around the
world like all the foods like the same
ingredients and same different [__] yeah
but you know what's strange too is that
like when something is a status symbol
in one country like they're all going to
adopt that right like they're all going
to be American in ways where it's like
prestigious looking but then like
fashion has always not been American in
the way because like when you're in
America everybody's wearing European
Brands to be the high status so it's
like a funny [__] thing like they
wear European brands in an American Way
in other countries or Europeans that
came to America and blew up the brand
like far or whatever like and then they
created something and it went back and
then over and over yeah we wear their
[__] but they watch our movies yeah it's
like to our music which is like the joke
behind Ali G it's like he's he's copying
another culture that's copying another
culture yeah it's like it's layers away
which is like the weirdest thing is
crazy is there anything original like
just
purely not what do you call it like I
think it's we're just like all
Innovative and then just there's no
other influences that came in and
changed it it's like impossible if you
think about doing their own spin on a a
thing that everyone's already done and
they all came together and was like oh
you do the same [__] the same [__] oh
that's crazy unless you're born in
isolation on an island what about the LA
homeless tents I don't see other people
having those yeah Portland oh they do
American homeless tents americ homeless
where originating is culture I don't see
that like in you know the funniest thing
to me though so like I'm just
entertaining this conversation but like
at the end of the day like our actual
culture is more Regional and I think
that being a Californian La Southern
Californian is like like probably way
more what we are than saying like you're
Chinese or cuz if we go to like if I go
to Japan right now no one thinks I'm
Japanese and if you guys go to China no
one thinks you're Chinese no one's going
to they're not going to actually accept
Chinese like you go to the locals and
they're all going to be like you're
American well Japan is Hardcore about
that right they really won't even like
let you say you're Japanese thank you
yes he's not Anthony that guy just lied
but Bart that's Bart for
sure did you tell them you're Anthony
yeah tell them more things about you as
Anthony tell them you're
gay 7 eight why the [__] did you say
that all right look at that okay just
going to go have more sex with my
boyfriend now thank you very much for
the
food thank
you saying something like that all right
thanks man I'm just going to go get
continue getting [__] in my ass get
some calories so I can get mouth [__]
[Music]
for